why does regularization help with
overfitting why does it help with
reducing variance problems let's go
through a couple examples to gain some
intuition about how it works so recall
that our high bias high variance and
right just right pictures from earlier
video I look something like this now
let's be a fitting a large and deep
neural network I know I haven't drawn
this one too large or too deep but let's
do things on your network and is
currently overfitting so you have some
cost function right J of W B equals some
of the losses like so all right
and so what we do for a regularization
was add this extra term that penalizes
the weight matrices from being to launch
we said that was a for being a small so
why is it that shrinking the l2 norm or
the Frobenius norm of the parameters
might cause less overfitting one piece
of intuition is that if you you know
crank the regularization lambda to be
really really base they'll be really
incentivized to set the weight matrices
W to be reasonably close to zero so one
piece of inversion is maybe set the ways
to be so close to zero for a lot of
hidden units there's basically fevering
out along the impact of these hidden
units an adapter case then you know this
much simplified new network becomes a
much smaller neural network in fact it's
almost like the logistic regression
Union you know bin stack multiple layers
B and so that will take you from this
overfitting case much closer to the left
towards a high bias case but hopefully
there'll be an intermediate value of
lambda the results in the result closer
to this just right case in the middle
but the intuition is that by cranking up
lambda to be really big it will set W
close to zero which in practice this
isn't actually what happens the
can think of it as zeroing out or at
least reducing the impacted law the
hidden units so you end up with what
might feel like a simpler network like
this closer and closer to as if you were
just using logistic progression the
intuition of completely zeroing out a
bunch of hidden units isn't quite right
it turns out that what actually happens
and it will still use all the hidden
units but each of them will just have a
much smaller effect but you do end up
with a simple network and as if you have
a smaller network that is therefore less
prone to overfitting so I'm not sure
this intuition helps but when you
implement regularization in the primary
exercise you actually see some of these
variance reduction results yourself
here's another attempt at additional
intuition for why regularization helps
prevent overfitting and for this I'm
going to assume that we're using the 10h
activation function which looks like
this right so there's a G of Z equals 10
H of Z so if that's the case notice that
so long as Z is quite small so the Z
takes on only a smallish range of
parameters maybe around here then you're
just using the linear regime of the
Technische function there's only a Z is
allowed to wonder up you know to larger
values or smaller values like so that
the activation function starts to become
less linear so the intuition you might
take away from this is that it launder
the regularization parameter is launched
then you have that your parameters will
be relatively small because they are
penalized to be large in the cost
function and so the weights W are small
then because Z is equal to w right and
then technically plus B or but if W
tells you very small then Z will also be
low to be small and in particular is Z
ends up taking relatively small values
just invicible range then G of Z will be
roughly linear so it's as if every layer
will be
roughly linear as it is just linear
regression and we saw on course one that
if every layer is linear then your whole
network is just a linear network and so
even a very deep network but a deep
network where the linear activation
function is at the end they only able to
compute the linear function so it's not
able to you know fit those very very
complicated decisions very nonlinear
decision boundaries that allow it to you
know really a over fit right the
datasets like we saw on the overfitting
high variance case on the previous slide
so just to summarize um if the
regularization term is very large the
parameters W very small so Z will be
relatively small kind of ignoring the
effect would be for now but so Z is
relatively so Z be relatively small or
really should say it takes on a small
range of values and so the activation
function this chain HCA will be
relatively linear and so your whole
neural network will be computing
something not too far from a big linear
function which is therefore a pretty
simple function about in a very complex
highly nonlinear function and so it's
also much less able to open it and again
when you implement regularization for
yourself in the current exercise you'll
be able to see some of these effects
yourself before wrapping up our
discussion on regularization I just want
to give you one implementational tip
which is that when influencing
regularization we took our definition of
the cost function J and we actually
modified it by adding this extra term
that penalizes the waste being too large
and so if you implement gradient descent
one of the steps to debug gradient
descent is to plot the cost function J
as a function of the number of
iterations of gradient descent and you
want to see that the cost function J
your decreases monotonically after every
iteration of gradient
and if you're implementing
regularization then please remember that
J now has this new definition if you
plot the old definition of J just this
first term then you might not see a
decrease monotonically so to divide
gradients and make sure you're plotting
you know this new definition of J that
includes this second term as well
otherwise you might not see J decrease
monotonically on every single iteration
so that's it for l2 regularization which
is actually a regularization technique
that I use the most in training people
learning models in deep learning does
another sometimes use regularization
techniques called drop out
regularization let's take a look at that
in the next video